[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony [ __ ] him
[Music]
monday
monday monday
will this week be worse for trump than
last week
we shall see
lindsey graham is not coming off with a
great week so far
jim jordan is puking up lies as
as usual he is seeing imaginary fbi
agents
all over the place i see fbi agents
jim jordan says a lot of things a lot of
things
that and most of it is all complete
horse [ __ ]
all of it
almost every single bit of it this is a
guy who looks away
when college students
are being sexually
assaulted and he sees fbi agents they
were in my office i think i don't know
they had they had really they had they
looked like real fbi shirts on in fbi
hats they looked real to me
i was [ __ ] idiot
of course he says it on fox news which
makes it even less credible
of course of course
my guess is is there's one one retired
agent that he got drunk with
that is a cue and honor and he turned it
into 14. he was so wasted that he saw 14
agents standing in front of him retired
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ] 14
agents
give me a break
whistleblowers he calls them of course
i don't know if that's a an old term
from his wrestling years but
we shall see jim jordan is a [ __ ]
liar
he's a liar
why would anyone think he's credible
going on fox news and saying anything at
all anything
lindsey graham's in a bunch of trouble
it seems this morning lindsey graham is
not not going to have a great week this
week the federal judge says uh yeah
you're gonna have to uh
i don't know um
abide by that lawful subpoena that's the
thing you're gonna have to do uh dr oz
is being humiliated in the news of
course what's new there
oh dr oz
dr oz dr oz jim acosta
made an absolute fool
out of andrew yang so that's kind of
nice we've got that to look forward to
today but i also want to announce that
at the bottom of the hour we're gonna
have a special interview
special interview with comedian ben
glebe
it's such a great interview
i've been wanting to ask him
questions about his abortion debate with
charlie kirk
for a long time i love that clip that
you know the dolphin fetus clip you know
which one i'm talking about you'll see
it you'll see it during the interview we
play it during the interview
but ben
describes ben describes how he
negotiated that interview with turning
points usa and charlie kirk
and how he made that moment happen
for our sake
because it's such a great moment
it's such a great moment
such a great moment
in history
an internet history really
but he describes how he actually
received that moment how charlie kirk
couldn't bury that moment forever
and ben describes that he also talks
about his brand new special that just
came out last night
on uh helium comedy
their youtube channel it's the mad king
so come watch that um interview at the
bottom of the hour me and gabe talk to
ben glebe
comedian
he gives us a lot of uh political
commentary he does political commentary
political and social commentary not just
comedy but he also tries to use comedy
to give commentary so we appreciate ben
coming and telling us the story
of how he
humiliated
charlie kirk it's great it's great and
charlie kirk had to buy him a huge
dinner so stick around for that
interview
you are not going to want to miss that
at the bottom of the hour today
and also
i've got the link in in the description
here to ben's new
comedy
special so go watch the link is down
below
make sure you save that for
later and go watch ben's new comedy
splash it's special it is hilarious this
is his second one hour special it's
called the mad king
go check that out in the links below
you notice that the overlay is a little
different this morning all the names and
everything support pro-democracy speech
today
you can go to
support.tonymichaelspod.com
and you can support pro-democracy speech
today and you
should so do that for us
spread that spread that link around if
you would show us support here at the
show but not just us um here at the show
pro democracy speech is so important
and we are just one little
cog in the wheel of pro-democracy speech
the midas touch network is doing great
things other people are doing great
things we have to have to have to hold
these fascists accountable and quit with
this both sides [ __ ]
you know i'm totally against the bull
side [ __ ]
i can't stand it when someone's like oh
democrats republicans did the same
we must we must give fascist air time
we have to give their their fascist
talking points here no you do not you do
not have to give fascist air time to
talk about their nonsense you do not
have to have them lie
on television
we've watched cash patel over the
weekend
i don't know why
why why i think it's hilarious
absolutely hilarious
that cash patel and devin nunes who used
to work together apparently i guess cash
patel used to work for devin nunes when
he was a congressman
they were picked out to be the fall guys
devin nunes was picked out to be the
fall guy for for fraud social
he left his seat in congress to go take
the fall for fraud social
what whatever crimes are being committed
over there devin nunes is now the ceo
trump knew that now of course you know a
lot of people assume that fraud social
was committing crimes before devin nunes
became the ceo but that's trump's mo
that's what he always does
he goes he starts to commit crime he's
like ah someone's gonna need to be a
fall guy for this crime so then he picks
out one of his lackeys
devin nunes probably owes him something
you know
owes him a favor probably
so devin nunes uh goes in beast and is
the fall guy for fraud social but then
cash patel apparently over the weekend
we have uh there was a letter released
from the cheeto dust mobster grandpa
poopy's pants himself back in june
making cash patel
the seesayer of the presidential record
of his presidential records
i wonder i wonder why that could be i
wonder if donald trump is looking for
something to go oh what meat one meat
he was the one that was responsible for
my records
i have no idea i don't know what records
are
me no me no locks paper this is really
[ __ ] dumb the the cheeto dust monster
donald trump
the orange mango mussolini jesus
was freaking the [ __ ] out
on fraud social this weekend absolutely
losing his mind because his narrative is
being ripped apart
at every single turn
the fascists in congress they held a
press conference uh last week we covered
it where elise stefanik and mike turner
stood up to defend donald trump the
indefensible
treason espionage
and then this weekend mike turner goes
on the sunday shows and makes even a
bigger fool of himself which is not
surprising and i'm to show that video
later on in the second hour after the
interview with ben glebe that's what
we're going to do today we're going to
do the first hour here at the bottom of
the hour we're going to play the
interview in the top of the next hour
we're going to start the [ __ ] last round
up where we round up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends because we
have a lot of video footage to get to
over the weekend we have the andrew yang
footage i'm sure by the time we get to
it lindsey graham will have some footage
here now we have the all the sunday show
footage we have jim jordan claiming that
he he sees dead people i mean fbi agents
we have steve ducey and killed me they
can't they can't figure out if fox and
friends is for violence against the fbi
or against it they're not really sure
what kind of rhetoric they want to have
on their show
ducey's like oh yeah
on fox and friends this is this morning
even and they've been trying this out
they've been trying this bit out oh
ducey says oh
the fbi is law enforcement if you back
the blue then you must back the fbi and
the dangerous rat he even called on the
president this morning
i'm the former president he called him
the president they always call him the
president over there not the [ __ ]
president shouldn't we give him an
asterisk like he shouldn't even be able
to be called the former president
[ __ ] that guy
but steve ducey says donald trump
should should call on to stop the
violent rhetoric
and kill me he's like well you know
maybe not
all in the same breath but
that's that was the that was the
sticking point for kill me but
but the fbi is really bad and they're
going after they're going after our our
orange muslin jesus and we can't have
that and we got to really stop the fbi
so keep ramping up the rhetoric that way
people threaten them this is really
[ __ ] dumb
we we watched
in cincinnati as some
lunatic some maglidite was killed in a
cornfield because he got deluded by the
former guy
and by the the america first nazi party
absolutely got deluded
took a nail gun and an ar-15 to an fbi
office where he was chased down i-71
ended up in a cornfield
and they had to
get rid of him because he just wouldn't
quit
his delusion
was fatal
and we watched this weekend in arizona
as a bunch of [ __ ] trump trumped up
white geist with guns show up at another
fbi office on federal property
you know it really is kind of funny
do you remember back in 2020 when they
were complaining that people were at
federal buildings and seattle
and
and other places around the country
they're burning cities they're burning
cities and here these people are showing
up wanting to overturn federal buildings
you know there was an executive order
signed i'm not sure if it still stands
but it might still be there i'd say our
president in the united states needs to
enforce it that's what i think [ __ ] them
[ __ ] them
14 fbi agents and this is more of the
same this is more of jim jordan
trying to stoke
trying to stoke violence on the right
trying to rile up moglodites right who
gives he didn't give a [ __ ] if it's real
he doesn't care if there's actually 14
fbi agents because what they're trying
to do now now that they're going to be
accused
of turning their supporters on the fbi
and committing violence in this country
terrorism because we know they're all
domestic terrorists they define
themselves that at the nuremberg rally
in texas the cpac last a couple weeks
ago and there's probably going to be
another one next week i'm sure they they
run these nazi rallies at least two or
three times a month
but jim jordan
goes on fox news
and decides that there's only he's like
well maybe they'll believe there's 14
good agents
right maybe in the whole fbi
our supporters will now believe that
there's at least at least 14. i think
that's where he pulled that number from
i mean straight out of his ass but he
thought now they'll believe at least
that there's 14
agents that are that are cult members
which i'm sure there's probably 14 maybe
more
hell there might be two or three times
that that are cult members i don't know
how are we supposed to know anymore you
can't [ __ ] tell with these folks
but i think he thought man these these
moglodites the this
this fox audience will believe that
there's at least
at least
14 fbi cult members
surely
so he pulls that number out of his ass
and he calls him whistleblowers
which you know it's all a bunch of
[ __ ] he's lying out his ass
any time jim jordan [ __ ] opens his
mouth he's lying
how can you believe a [ __ ] thing he
says
but here on fox news he says 14 fbi
agents have told him that it's a bunch
of baloney it's not baloney dumb
[ __ ] we saw the receipt
we your own eyes you do not you do not
have to do anything but believe your own
eyes here
that every single fbi agent every single
person that was a part of that search
warrant
who went into donald trump's home at
mar-a-lago
and found all the [ __ ] in his safe that
he was trying to hide and all the stuff
in melania's closet that he was trying
to hide because he keeps talking about
that the former guy keeps talking about
those two things melania's closet and is
safe he keeps talking about him he won't
shut the [ __ ] up about him
and i believe it's because
that's where he was hiding the [ __ ] that
he didn't want anyone to find and we
also know that the the
the closed circuit television
his security cameras
are now showing that they were trying to
move boxes around from room to room he
wasn't keeping it behind a padlock
that's all [ __ ] and any and that's
why he says this stuff anything he says
you can just better well bet he's
telling on himself
like that's all you gotta do and really
honestly i wish i was sean hannity or
some other dumb [ __ ] would do
like a two or three hour interview and
just ask this guy questions about the
documents that he had down at mar-a-lago
and how he took him from the white house
and how he got him down there what he
did with him once he you know who looked
at him who he showed them to i'm sure he
would just [ __ ] say everything that
we need right out in the [ __ ] open
because he thinks he's impervious to
this stuff he's even acting as if and
cash patel is doing the same thing that
they have some kind of magic power over
declassification the [ __ ] are you
talking about he's not the president
he's not the president he's not the
president and then he invokes barack
obama's name into the situation if
barack obama has anything to do with his
dumb ass stealing classified documents
he's claiming barack obama has 33
million documents that he's he stole and
he's taken to chicago you are astute you
are stupid [ __ ] man
dumb [ __ ]
the documents that barack obama is
trying to get to chicago are in the
archive in washington dc in the custody
of national archives where they're
supposed to be
and there's a few pieces
of presidential history while barack
obama was in office that he has custody
of that he also wants to get taken to
his library in chicago which isn't that
nice that barack obama actually has a
library in chicago my guess is and what
we should do in this country is not give
donald trump a library [ __ ] him
no [ __ ] him we should not give him a
library what it should be is an evidence
locker down at the national archives
that's what it should be as an evidence
locker not a library
i mean really the only library this guy
is fitted for is a coloring book factory
jesus [ __ ] christ
but i can't wait i can't wait who else
is excited to see
the footage
from the closed circuit television of
these dummies committing crimes on their
security cameras
who's ready i'm ready for it there's
[ __ ] tapes folks
there's tapes of them committing crimes
it's gonna be fantastic it's gonna be
fantastic
this guy is [ __ ] he is completely
[ __ ] there is no which way around it
and really everyone's wondering who the
informant is i've been thinking about it
over the weekend and i'm trying to
figure out who has the most to lose here
melania seems like she's got a lot to
lose
i mean
if trump goes down it all comes tumbling
down
then she's stuck with with his with his
dumb ass kid
and she where is she gonna go what's she
gonna do then
how is she gonna pretend that she's rich
that's gonna be that's gonna be a
problem so maybe maybe there's some
motive there for her to be the informant
there's definitely a motive for jared
kushner to be the informant
oh baby i'm sure the feds are breathing
down his goddamn neck about all the
crimes that he's committed and all the
foreign money he's taken yeah i bet that
i bet
i bet there's reason to believe that he
would inform on his father-in-law to
save his own ass
jared kushner that is
there's a whole whole host of people
that could be the informant
i actually believe that that when the
national archives went
to retrieve these documents
the times that they did retrieve which
they got 15 boxes apparently there's 12
more boxes of course there were probably
a lot of a duplicates because there's
got to be a copy machine somewhere in
mar-a-lago
but i would bet
that in that team of national archivists
who went to retrieve those documents in
the original
raid
no they just came to get their [ __ ]
dummy
when they went to get their [ __ ] the
original time the national archivist
probably had fbi agents embedded with
them posing as national archivist
to make sure that any crimes were
committed that they could sniff them out
and looks like they did
and this nonsense that he can declassify
a thing any time he wants and
he's got a magic power like michael
scott does to declare bankruptcy he can
just declare something declassified
number one that's not really how it
works
when you're the president of the united
states or how classified information
works number two
there's a process once it's declassified
to unmarket it's all marked it's all
marked in its proper form and he stole
it a lot of this stuff even if it's
declassified
that doesn't make a difference
it still cannot be out in the open a lot
of this stuff has to be viewed in a
skiff
it doesn't matter what the
classification is it's national security
and that's what the espionage act
the the the actual crimes that are
probably going to be charged on this
[ __ ] are about now the other
thing you have to remember here
is everyone keeps talking about the
three statutes that were in the warrant
that doesn't mean that's the only thing
they can charge him with
that's not the only thing they can
charge him with and the then the dumbass
even on fraud social let the cat out of
the bag
talking about how
oh
they took stuff that didn't have to do
with the warrant yeah
in other words oh [ __ ]
they found more crimes what am i gonna
do
of course they found more crime in his
office
this guy's a [ __ ] criminal
so i would imagine that there's just
gonna be a whole host of charges now
i've changed my mind i actually believed
that the department of justice was going
to charge donald trump with one crime
and one crime they could prove and go
after that and really stick the arrow in
as deep as they could
i don't think that's what's gonna happen
anymore i think they're going to pile as
many charges as they can on top of this
dumbass as many as they possibly can
stick to him
because they've got the evidence
ooh baby it's bound to be a good week
isn't it it just gets better and better
like democracy really is kicking in here
isn't it it's really kicking in and the
fascists are terrified they're like oh
you can't do this before an election
yeah yeah you can do anything
you have to do justice when justice has
to be done especially when our national
security is at risk and the former
president united states is committing
espionage
and selling our secrets to foreign
powers because you know you know that's
what his intention was
the other piece of news that is most
significant here
is apparently the judge
would not release another part of the
search warrant maybe just maybe
maybe just maybe
that search warrant is going to search a
certain casket at betminster i'm just
saying
i'm just saying i'm just throwing that
out there in the universe i don't know
for sure
maybe just maybe they want to find out
what the hell is in that casket that was
buried in the ditch off off hole number
one
at the golf course at betminster
the cemetery of betminster oh my god
everyone make sure to use the link down
below support pro democracy speech you
see it here on the screen
support.tonymichaelspod.com you can use
the qr code support us we appreciate the
audience all the new listeners remember
we air live every single weekday monday
through friday on youtube twitter and
twitch for two full hours
we also simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page for those two full hours
every single weekday we are here live
giving you the strategic outrage that
you need to go out and engage in your
democracy because baby democracy is
winning stick around right after the
break we're going to have the interview
with ben glebe he's going to talk about
how he schooled he schooled charlie kirk
in an abortion debate stick around don't
go anywhere that interview comes up
right after this break
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
[Music]
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only 50 dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[ __ ] we're back to the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back
to the show thanks for sticking around
through the break we have a special
guest with us stand up comedian the host
and head writer of emmy nominated game
show
idiot test he also had his first hour
stand up special neuronic gangster on
showtime he's a star of chelsea lately
tbs
called him one of the funniest comedians
working today he's also an anchor for
the young turks where he also does his
own video series for rebel hq three
times a week and his second
our special drops
uh it actually dropped yesterday on
helium comedy youtube page go check it
out welcome ben glebe thanks ben for
joining us here on the tony michaels
podcast how have you been my friend i've
been great especially pleased now that
you nailed that intro and you were so
insecure about it i know well it was a
it was a big intro i was a little
nervous because as my audience knows i
completely [ __ ] up intros gabe knows
this my audience knows this so that's
like the first one i think gabe is that
the first one i really had a slam dunk
on yeah no no hiccups along the way that
we know of on camera yeah i'm not gonna
point out the two hiccups there actually
were because it was so close to being
right right right well there are a
couple mentioned that i was one of the
stars of chelsea lately because the show
hasn't been on the air in about oh wow
that is the fears or the fact that it's
helium comedy studios presenting the
special i wouldn't mention that because
you did such a good job tony on the rest
of it well you know i'm glad you
mentioned those so that way the audience
knows exactly
the the history of chelsea lately and
that it must you must go to the helium
studios com whatever you whatever the
actual name go to wherever just search
the mad king on youtube
then you'll find it that's it hey that
brings me to a point because you sent me
an advanced copy of this special and
it's great everyone should go watch it
it's hilarious um it doesn't just have
political and social issues which is
kind of the issues i want to talk to you
about today um but
what who are the mad ones what is that
what what's the mad ones i want to ask
you about that real quick absolutely
yeah thank you for watching and for the
kind words um the mad ones are my fans
across the globe um
it
it's a name really that kind of took
shape during the pandemic when i when we
were all shut down and i created nowhere
comedy
which is the world's first virtual
comedy venue and became the best and we
created this community and i started
doing this with this weekly show at the
time now i do it about once a month
called glebe off the top crowd work and
improvise madness and the people that i
tend to regularly with my were my die
hard fans and i called them i started
calling them the mad ones after the
kerouac quote the only people for me are
the mad ones yeah i got you and they
started calling me the mad king
and which is part of why the specials
called that and these amazing group of
people that attend
most of the shows i do online they
travel around north america to see my
shows live i mean
some of my fans have come and seen me
just in the last year or two in the same
people in dc
vancouver
uh indianapolis
uh
dallas they just travel around
philly where i tape the special and
they're amazing um and so i wanted to
shout them out in the special quite a
bit as far as just giving them some some
homage and some love
and uh
so that that's the mad ones well we we
love our fans here too they're called
the [ __ ] fans so i know [ __ ] them fam
so i know i know you know [ __ ] i'm fine
you even [ __ ] up that intro
yeah and half i [ __ ] up every intro i
told you i told you this is a thing that
happens here on the tony michaels but
nice this special though
you mentioned one of my
all-time favorite charlie kirk pieces of
content that you are in you it it is it
is a very famous piece of content i
actually think gabe we've probably
played it on our podcast i don't know
three or four times i [ __ ] hate
charlie it's a it's it is definitely an
evergreen type of uh piece of content
i love that yeah i hope that clip never
leaves him it's the dolphin fetus clip
it it is the dolphin fetus clip and i
think people have have watched it i'm
gonna show it again here um really quick
because i just i just want people to
remember exactly what the what the clip
is but
i i have a few questions about this clip
and the reason why is because we've had
another friend of the show rachel
bittikoffer went and she went to debate
night or whatever that i think that's
yeah that's what he calls a debate
with charlie kirk he she went and
debated him and she sent me the footage
and i was like hmm that's kind of funny
and here's the reason why i have a
question because i wonder did he
intentionally send you this footage that
you were able to
you know make into a clip or
is this part of he actually put this in
that debate night like he put it in
well listen i'm a very strong negotiator
it's part of being the mad king is not
taking not letting other people set your
terms and so uh when he reached out to
me he famously reached out to
congressman eric swalwell
and he offered him to be on debate night
and swalwell instead put his dm on blast
and said i'm not going to go and debate
an insurrectionist that makes me and my
family unsafe
i instead accepted the exact same dm
that charlie slid into mine with
and said i'm going to go debate an
insurrectionist and humiliate them and
do what i can to make sure this person
is weakened um because they are an enemy
of the people anybody that
that supports turning over an obviously
fair election
and did so by sending buses of people
there and encouraging them to fight
uh deserves to be
taken down and you know
there are people that even don't want
this special to be
heard i was telling you guys how fair
but i don't care i'll announce it on
there my facebook page was as was was
hacked taken away from me stolen got
recovered last night and was just stolen
again this morning there are forces that
don't want you to see this special and
we cannot let them i will not let them
i've worked too hard for this
and um
we need to get you know
some of the truth and keeping these
idiot these male intended [ __ ]
honest and so
not that my special's gonna do you know
gonna change anything on the grand
scheme but we all need to be talking and
speaking our truth and speaking truth to
power as much as we can and every little
bit counts um so i negotiated very
strongly with charlie's people that they
had to allow me to shoot my own iphone
footage of the whole debate oh wow so
this so this actual this clip came from
your iphone so what you're saying is is
charlie did cut this out of no version
no i also made them promise that i would
not do it unless they agreed to cut out
zero content unless there was just like
dead air and so they had to agree to
that in writing
and they did
and so um they released it but what they
did do sneakily at the end of the debate
in the bonus time
um
they did cut out the bonus time where i
then call him out on funding the
insurrection attempt and the protests at
the ellipse or rather the approaches
that led to the insurrection and i got
him to storm off of his own show and
storm off of his own set did you ever
shoot did you so they cut that they cut
that out i that's on my full debate on
myyoutube.com b glebe you can see the
whole debate's an hour 20 it's the extra
15 minutes that we do that shows that
happen and because i released it and
released a separate meme showing that
and so he was forced to then show it he
then uploaded a second version of the
whole debate that did include that so he
could pretend like he didn't cut it out
right he definitely did cut it out
because both versions are still live and
the second version he called me
so-called comedian and that's the title
you push me on your show bro what does
that speak to your own booking ability
if you're so called but my favorite part
of the charlie kirk negotiations not
only did i get all those details set so
that i knew i would be protected and
that i could post all these clips much
as i want but i further got them to
agree to fly me out to a studio in
arizona put me up in a dope hotel give
me a car service and pay for all of my
meals when i was there so right after i
was kicked out of his studio and
security escorted me off after i made
charlie run like a baby off his own set
i still had a car service the rest of
the day just wait take me and my
girlfriend now fiance to a very nice
sushi restaurant arizona and we had a
270 sushi dinner on charlotte
oh my god
you know i thought i thought i thought
that this dolphin fetus piece of content
was the best piece of content but right
now in this moment that story that
you're telling is a damn good piece of
charlie kirk content you realize that
the mad king strikes again
what's that i said the mad king strikes
again that's right man and and aside
from that one meme too if you don't want
to watch the whole debate we released on
my instagram as a little christmas gift
to everybody during the holidays last
year 12 days of kirk's and ass and
every day we release the new meme where
i own him from that debate all the topic
of abortion a great topic for the
holidays isn't it oh absolutely well i'd
like to get into the uh abortion
abortion um
subject nobody's getting into my
uterus that
let's let's watch let's watch the uh the
famous
charlie kirk getting schooled on
abortion in 15 seconds
do you truly in your heart of hearts
truly believe that this is a human being
this without a doubt without a doubt yes
this is a dolphin fetus
without a doubt a dolphin fetus is a
human being this is a human being
but
quite differently
you just confirmed that a dolphin in in
life you confuse dolphins for human
babies often
you go to sea world and you're like
somebody's got human babies in that
aquarium ben
did you have this whole thing prepared
and you knew you were going to strike or
you do you just carry a little
brown bag full of uh dolphins
pictures in your i usually do carry a
brown bag of dolphin fetuses that's just
my sexual kink it's the only way i can
come but um i happened to bring it to
this location because i had that moment
planned i knew exactly how i wanted to
phrase it i knew exactly i wanted to
give him fairly a chance to say yes or
no that he believed that was a a human
or not i wasn't trying to trap him but i
had an exact way to phrase it where i
said to him
i showed the i plan to show the photo to
the audience and then to him and say do
you and your heart of hearts believe and
he said yes i gave him an out i said
i
i said you do or whatever i said i give
i said do you believe in your heart of
hearts this is a human being and he goes
without a doubt and i go without a doubt
i give him a chance
he could have doubted at that moment
i think so i can't tell the photo right
he goes yes
absolutely and so i talk about it in my
special as well um and a little bit of
of of the behind the scenes of that um
because uh he is a
bad person
i just love the stare off to whoever
whoever was on set or the producer or
cameraman was like oh [ __ ] yes
yes that'll haunt him forever and um
when i was in arizona my now fiance um
didn't understand why i needed to stop
on the way to i had to have the car
service drop us off on the way to the
set at an office max or office depot or
whatever i'm like i got to print this
photo she's like who cares gets a whole
debate you've been preparing for two
weeks i'm like i need this dolphin photo
picture trust me did anyone have a store
40 million views across the platform
and it it went as big as possible did
anyone at the store as you as you were
printing it out did they stop and go
oh okay yeah i mean they they looked a
little weird thank god
because they knew his adult was not
pro-life yes they knew for sure thank
god that dude
was not a kirk supporter in phoenix
arizona you do never know um but also it
was another fun part of that day was it
was the greatest um
debate prep vibe i've ever had um before
a serious moment like that because my
fiance loves lazy rivers and the hotel
they put us up at the arizona grand
resort has like some huge lazy river
around the whole resort it's a water
park
and
so i wanted to i was studying for weeks
i was being you know advised by narrow
and planned parenthood unofficially
unofficially people that worked there um
were giving me advice
and uh
and i still have more research to do so
we literally were in a lazy river and i
was on my phone researching abortion
rights and talking points and
counterpoints and she was holding onto
my tube from her tube and just every 10
minutes that she was relaxed and maxed
out as could be i'd be like babe do you
mind looking up the 13th amendment 14th
amendment can you give me the full
language of that hey look look up for me
real quick dobbs if you can with a full
language of dobbs and she's telling me
about abortion details i'm putting into
my brain while little children who were
not aborted were floating by
very unaborted uh
fetuses inside these tubes that were in
the lazy river my favorite kind of kids
are non-aborted kids oh really okay well
that's good that's good
so the special is great and you release
two clips on instagram and the one
actually is what caused me to go hey i
need i need to get a hold of this guy i
love the charlie kirk 15 seconds dolphin
fetus abortion video that is a fantastic
piece of content i gotta ask him how he
got that piece of con or how he got that
video from charlie kirk now we know now
we know that there was another camera in
the room but i want to play first this
is hilarious the the airplane uh clip
you put on instagram of your special
let's play that real quick how come we
can never get the volume of the
announcements right on airplanes
we've had aviation for decades no one's
told this to the airlines
always the announcements are far too
loud or far too quiet
and the important ones are far too quiet
and the dumb ones are far too loud
the captain of this vessel gets on he's
always like
[Music]
i'm sorry did you say engine fire
and then five minutes later a flight
attendant comes on we're gonna be coming
down the aisle with the united mile
blaster car we're gonna give you 50 000
bonus miles
can you use that speaker for the death
announcement
because i'm sitting here sucking my own
and i don't know what's next
so so so ben clearly yeah you do just a
little more than political and social
comedy obviously um which i think that's
a hilarious clip thank you
so tell us about the special though
because i've watched it but how long did
it take you to work through this
material because it's a full hour a
whole hour how long did it take me to
write that stuff i mean basically this
is the material that i've been
developing since my last special and
it's been some time because of this
weird
slow moving business so uh my last
special dropped in 2016. so it's been
about
six years in the making of developing
this new stuff and um
it's the best pulled out of multiple
hours of stuff i've been touring with
these last handful of years
and i just you know talk about
a very wide range of things in this
special like you said i talk about i
mean just as like as a quick rundown of
some topics i talk about
um
lgbtq rights and
bathroom protests i talk about national
anthem protest i do a whole long chunk
on religion on the constitution i talk
about the me too movement i make fun of
over wokeness i also
make fun of
um
i make fun of girls that are too into
mermaids i tell stories about extra
girls
i the girls that want to be mermaids i
talk about um
some stories about ex-girlfriends and
things they did that were strange weird
dates i had weird proclivities of mine
fights i've been in therapy stories
about me discovering that i had adhd and
being in therapy um just our crumbling
planet living in a post-truth era bias
racism i cover all these different
things technology robots taking over and
just some weird stories about me and my
girlfriend being very lazy humans and
overeating on the couch we cover it all
in this special and so i've been
developing the material for a long time
and i jam packed in a lot of stuff like
not to talk [ __ ] about other comedians
but just to talk a little bit of [ __ ]
the most special that i watch these days
it's an hour of like very long stories
that you might get four stories in an
hour you might laugh three or four times
in the whole hour special if that from
some of the greats even people are
considered the greats
and i hope watching this special you're
going to get like
30 topics in an hour and four minutes
it's more than an hour and i think
you're going to laugh 50 plus times if
not a hundred times i'm hoping to keep
you rolling for an hour plus and this is
a different experience i think
well it was absolutely hilarious and i
love that you did walk through all those
topics i mean you did it so well one of
those topics being religion
and really right now in our country we
have sitting congress people
a woman in georgia specifically who
claims that she is a self-proclaimed
christian white nationalist or whatever
she's saying i mean it's it feels like
she's saying she's a nazi but i want to
play a clip here before we get into that
too deep uh that also was on instagram
where you talk about uh god jesus and
bumper stickers yes indeed because
people get so hung up on labels you see
everywhere bumper stickers that say like
jesus is god read the bible
and whether or not you believe jesus god
it's just kind of ridiculous to cite as
backup proof
the only place that says he's god
that's like saying animals can talk
watch doctor doolittle
oh that that you know that reminds me
almost of the uh charlie kirk slam dunk
with the with the dolphin fetus there
when you're when you're going after
people with the bumper sticker well it's
because because what i try to do i i i
try to create moments that corner people
and like in in
perfect logic
that you can't disprove how are you
going to disprove that clip
there is no disproof to that it is a
perfect analogy you can believe jesus
god if you want and i say in the special
i respect all people this is a special i
think that is both progressive and crazy
as [ __ ] you can be both it's not a mole
that many have figured out but i've
figured it out you can be extreme and be
funny and say crazy things while also
not being cruel to people so people
should have whatever religious beliefs
they want ever gives them comfort but
put an asterisk on it like i say in the
special we think we're pretty poor but
to cite as oh it's this is fact it's in
the bible yeah that's the one place that
says it that's the book that says it
that's like exactly like saying
animals can talk because of doctor
doolittle because you watch the movie
yeah right right i don't remember who
played him eddie murphy or steve martin
one of the two i'm pretty sure but
they're not god do you understand the
point they're right right well getting
very riled up because i am the mad king
there's many uh definitions of mad i'm
partially wacky and weird i'm also
partially very angry i'm also very very
sleep deprived i'm on three hours sleep
right now i was working on artwork for
the special and editing an animated
intro for it until 9 00 am this morning
oh wow recover now my identity even
before we started this podcast so i'm
i'm very mad in many ways well so let's
let's talk about that anger and let's
direct it in a way that we can talk
about this white christian nationalism
because we watch
over the weekend um
this last weekend we saw cpac on the
banner and i think they did it as kind
of a joke
but they announced to the entire room we
are all domestic terrorists and they
they had it on the jumbotron as if it
was some kind of dig on liberals or
something and i was like you're you're
now branding yourselves as domestic
terrorists and that's what it feels like
when marjorie taylor green and some of
these other politicians are embracing
not just their christianity right but
they're saying you have to be christian
it is a christian nation and you have to
do these things and you have to think
the way i think or else and that's
that's the way it's starting to feel do
you get that sense a hundred percent i
mean lauren bober went as far as a week
or two ago saying that the government is
not supposed to dictate
how religions operate which they're not
but religions are supposed to dictate
how the government operates which is not
at all true that's a christian
nationalist a fundamentalist [ __ ]
opinion it's inaccurate and it's them
openly and overtly saying we only care
if you're white christians that is it a
marginal retailer green saying the same
thing this should be a christian
nationalist nation that it should not be
and you should get the [ __ ] out of this
nation if you believe that it is let
alone serve in the halls of power of
this nation right let alone being
someone that also supported and winked
at these interactions very strongly for
weeks leading up to it including the day
before and i think the day of as well i
mean these are horrible idiots that clip
i'm sure you're referring to partially
here uh at cpac of marjorie taylor green
in a jail cell fake reveal yeah crouched
down praying with brandon strzok
the also insurrectionist who served jail
time for it and who i also have
destroyed in a debate on my youtube
uh where i took on at the same time him
and tommy laron and aaron elmore in a
video on my youtube page called ben
glebe systematically destroys fox news
talking points
where i took all three of them on at
once
and
destroyed them on every single point and
i do play-by-play commentary in this
video how i destroyed them and i bounced
off the show and tore off my mic and
stormed off at once i hit the
peak level of their ignorance and racism
and cold heartlessness enough these
people do not have a place in our
government they don't have a place in
our country the only people who should
go back to where they came from is the
people that believe other people should
go back to where they came from people
who think that who push that should get
back on the [ __ ] mayflower or
whatever white bred vehicle they came
here on and go back to country of origin
and stop being these
isolationist
closed off [ __ ] that try to make
themselves feel better by oppressing
others and try to make people uh try to
make excuses for the fact that all of
their policies only benefit themselves
the very rich the very top greediest few
i talked about that in the special too
by making it seem like these culture
issues they use to divide us
which are complete non-issues also talk
about that in the special are completely
manufactured controversies that they use
to keep us unaware of or unfocused on
the fact that
they don't have policies that help the
average working man they're against
unions they're against time off they're
against paid maternity leave they're
against
better working conditions or against
raising the minimum wage they're against
every single thing that would help
working people but they get you real
riled up about abortion and about
bathrooms and about anthem kneeling
which hurts nobody
and they keep the country divided so i
take all that on the special i have a
bran i have a video that just dropped
the other day on exactly that too on my
rebel hq young turks videos where i just
break down
piece by piece how hannity uh now says
that if you wanna if you're having
trouble making ends meet in this country
just work more work 70 80 90 hours a
week
how about instead pay people a living
wage how does that sound right
well that that sounds like logic and it
probably goes against my bad
you would you would think you'd be like
oh that would make more sense if we just
did it this way and they i feel like
republicans are they really push through
the most inefficient ways of doing
something and they go well i don't
really give a [ __ ] what you guys are
doing as long as i'm able to line my
pockets and you know travel how i want
to travel and you know be where i want
to be without any of these constraints
that i want to project onto other people
and they're like oh my life my life is
great i'm good to go you know which is
exactly what you're talking about these
republicans will project their own
insecurities their own ego problems
everything onto other people to
to limit access and limit the rights
that they have within their own lives
and it's and most of it's not even
genuine it's not even their own
insecurities it's it's things they
realize are wedge issues they don't care
about those things they've all had
abortions they've all paid for abortions
all of these
rich unfaithful right-wing
congress people they're mostly horrible
hypocrites and
they just do it for wedge issue and it
affects their own life they don't
believe a damn thing that they say well
you know that brings up a good issue
before we we head out here is the
hypocrisy and we we it's been a great
week for democracy the last few weeks we
the the primary in kansas where
overwhelmingly the people in kansas said
no you're not going to take away our
[ __ ] rights that's not going to be a
thing that's going to happen you can go
[ __ ] yourselves even in a red state like
kansas you also we also watched the the
raid of donald trump whatever that may
come of that and then the i and i think
the best part of the raid honestly if i
was a woman i would have been made very
wet by that
right so so you would have you had
that brings up another character didn't
make me hard because that would have
been i would have been a little weird
like it wasn't sexual for me so i'm just
projecting on to a part of the
population that i can't relate to but
i'm assuming if i was a woman that would
have turned me on i don't know you don't
know well i mean it happens that way but
i get i guess where i was getting it
that that the raid more than anything
because it's important like what happens
and the crimes that he committed but
maybe a little hard probably right a
little just like a little chub just a
little you know
but the thing the thing that i think is
most important is the reaction of the
right-wing media that was the most
important thing about that rate not the
rate i mean the rate is probably
important itself like in history because
it's never happened before but in this
moment in the in the body of
where we are politically
right and this back and forth like
you're saying the hypocrisy and they're
full of [ __ ] and they don't actually
believe this stuff it's just the tail
wagging the dog type [ __ ]
but the actual reaction from the right
wing because they were freaking the [ __ ]
out last night and tonight so much so
that tucker carlson uh charlie kirk's
older brother couldn't even appear on
his show last night he had some wish.com
tucker fill in for him on fox news but
the reaction was so beautiful but really
i think it's so important and it it
really speaks to how their back is
against the wall because i actually
think that's the biggest fraud that
donald trump has wrought on our country
is that somehow there's this big support
for him and trumpism and all this
nonsense
well i think there is a big support you
don't think there's big support
well i actually think that it is a big
it is a large number of people but it's
a small percentage of our country and i
think a lot of it is that some people
need permission to say yeah okay i don't
actually believe in all that stuff i
just say it because it's it's like i say
all the time we're at the intersection
of wrestlemania and real life and a lot
of these people have made politics
they're wrestlemania right it's the it's
the saturday night thing that they do
that they pretend and they go to work
and oh you gotta like this and you gotta
like that and second amendment and
abortion and but they don't really
understand the inner workings of what is
happening i when roe v wade was
overturned by dobbs i said soon there
are going to be trumped up white dudes
that walk into a gas station in a red
state looking for condoms and the
clerk's going to go we don't have
[ __ ] condoms what do you mean you
don't have condoms well we don't have
condoms because you vote for republicans
and they ban condoms because they don't
like for you to do the things that they
want to do right and so that realization
that hey this affects you as much as it
affects the the woman that you don't
want to have an abortion right
i actually believe that there is a large
number of these quote unquote trump
supporters that aren't actually trump
supporters it's a go along to get along
thing it's i like the evil villain
because he feels good to me to like the
evil villain in this moment
and i think i think until we get to a
situation where we can make the evil
ones i'm talking about the bad ones the
ones that want to commit violence they
want to overturn our government they
want they do not want us to be a
democracy because it is a threat to
their fascism until we get them to crawl
back underneath the rock and they do not
have permission to do that kind of [ __ ]
anymore we're still going to have this
trouble in this country where this fraud
of trumpism
is is really rotting our country right
now i see what you mean yeah i totally
agree with that i do agree it's a very
small percentage of people that actually
understand what they're espousing right
i really believe that absolutely i think
it's a sadly enormous percentage
probably 30 to 40 percent of the country
that goes along with it that has been
tricked if they fall in one of three
categories they truly believe it and
they're evil people or they are very
dumb very very very gullible
and have been
hypnotized by you can't blame them to
some degree by a party and a media
ecosystem on the right that has
convinced them that
everything that is on the other side is
against them is fake is false is
cheating is taking away their rights is
making their life worse just raising
their taxes even though it's the exact
opposite
and
the other
section are people that are just kind of
nerdwells they're people that are just
not great folks that are like oh let me
root for the villain even though it's
real life i mean to some degree you
can't give them that much slack because
yeah they might not fully understand it
but they're aware that they're cheering
for a president who's acting like a like
he's a bad guy in wrestling they're you
know he's not roddy
rowdy roddy piper up there he's the
president and he's talking about real
lives he had them cheering the other day
i did a video about this rebel hq he
goes you all know biden the deaths under
biden were way worse than my deaths and
they go whoa
i mean you got a cheerline on a mount of
american deaths being more under one
than the other
which is physically accurate of wounds
to account for all the factors that
trump [ __ ] up but even if it was
accurate he has
you're cheering
for american death instead of being like
whoa i'm leaving this arena right now
because this is a pale
far too far and so
yes i don't know how we put it back in i
don't know how we how we think we need
some sort of truth
we need some sort of truth
uh some some unbiased bipartisan
of the people truth commission we need
to enforce
uh truth and advertising laws again
truth and broadcasting laws again we
need to make sure we do not allow people
to call themselves news they're just
blatant propaganda machines not based on
facts there are things we can do
but until we figure that out we have to
just you know make noise we have to make
it known we have to mock the people that
are trying to execute this we need to
laugh at them and uh
i think my special's a pretty good way
to do some of that well that that's
great what because me and gabe me and
dave are talking about exactly the topic
that you're saying is comedy dead is
satire dead is parody dead because these
people really make it difficult right
man you know to level up from where
they're at to get the satire and the
parody like even even the moment at cpac
where you've got you know marger taylor
green in a jail cell like that would
totally outside of the fact that people
kept tagging me and they thought that i
was the guy in the jail cell doing a bit
and i was like that is that is not me
i'm i'm not him
but the the fact that that people were
like oh yeah gabe would totally do this
in a video or this would totally be a
bit
means that like have we jumped the shark
here like are we just making like
real life making fun of itself like what
is the republican party is
non-stop you know 100 if they're not if
they're not doing one crazy uh drinking
their piss for covid they're doing
something else where you'd be like
this would be something you would make
fun of and they're like nope this is 100
genuine and you're like
what the [ __ ] is going on well they got
to own the libs you know that right yeah
a lot of this like it's it's again it's
a wrestling match you got to get your
your chair on the back thing but i i
well they're they're very sad that
slavery's over so they feel like they
have to own somebody
well that that is one way of putting it
ben i i think i think you're a warrior
in this fight i think the the the just
the videos that you put out just the
simple one of charlie kirk owning him
and mocking him like you said and just
exposing him for the fraud that he
really is um is is moving the needle and
i agree with you i think we have to
continue to do this stuff to move the
needle to eventually get shame the ones
who are dangerous to crawl back
underneath the rock to wake up some of
the ones that are just kind of
hypnotized by this all like you said
i couldn't agree more thank you guys for
doing your part in that fight as well
tell us one more time it dropped
yesterday but tell us one more time
exactly where to go so i don't [ __ ] it
up tell us where exactly where to go to
find your special your second one-hour
special tell us exactly where to go so
also easiest way in some ways is just
follow me on instagram or tick tock i
post five videos a week there are other
stand-up videos excuse me crowd work
where i make fun of the crowd uh
highlights of my rebel hq videos and my
link in bio on both my instagram and
twitter my instagram twitter is at ben
gleb b-e-n-g-l-e-i-b
the top link will be check out my new
hour special the mad king click that
it'll take you right to it or just go on
youtube helium comedy studios page
search for ben glebe the mad king or
probably just searching for that without
the studios we'll probably bring it up
ben glebe the mad king watch it sit down
with some popcorn and some beer or some
weed or some whatever maybe hard
cocktails whatever you do
flavored seltzer water if that's your
poison you know whatever you need but uh
get ready for a for a pretty in intense
comedy ride i think
well ben thank you very much for joining
us and don't be afraid to come back my
friend we'd love to talk i would love it
politics
we love laughing and we love talking
politics and we love we absolutely love
dogging on charlie kirk it's one of my
favorite
one of my favorites
thank you very much my friend you have a
good one everyone stick around we will
be right back
right after this break
we'll be right back
mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capitol have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup pardon blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome welcome welcome welcome back to
the show
what a great interview what a great
guest
hilarious
the comedian ben glebe
go check out his new
one hour comedy special
after the show
you're not gonna want to miss it the
link is down in the description
don't forget to go there and see
ben glebe's comedy special
welcome back to the show thanks for
joining us we're gonna we got a lot of
stuff to get to what a great
great
great interview gabe what did you think
of the interview i i couldn't help but i
think it was great it was great that
that basically leave is great
what the the the story about charlie
kirk is
i mean the icing on the cake where they
wouldn't had like like almost a 300 hour
dinner on charlie oh yeah charlie agreed
to that you know what getting his
[ __ ] crawl right you know that
bothered the [ __ ] out of him i mean the
way i i would imagine the fact that like
you know they're like all right get off
the set go go go go they leave and he's
like well
legally according the contract you got
to drive me wherever the [ __ ] i want to
go before i leave and also anything that
i expense for food you have to cover it
so i can only imagine him
paying for the sushi you know getting
sushi this expensive deal with his
girlfriend now fiance
and um and then
sending it in
and then somebody like we got an invoice
for like three hundred dollars for a
meal out here
after everything came out of the
building after they
for anyone who doesn't know uh charlie
kirk's little turning points usa
headquarters is in phoenix right it's in
arizona and he has like a five-story
building or some [ __ ] it's not like a
little bitty tiny office no these people
these people are serious about
destroying democracy they're absolutely
serious about it they do not [ __ ] around
actually there's been clips just in the
last day or so going around about
charlie kirk saying some dumb [ __ ] in
front of a big audience and then
cheering the dumb [ __ ] just like
marjorie taylor green i'm going to show
you a clip of margaret taylor green
gabe talking she doesn't understand how
windmills and solar panels work and that
batteries don't exist well we're going
to get we're going to get to that we're
going to get to that
but these but these people are dead
serious about destroying our democracy
they are serious about it they don't
give a [ __ ] they don't care what you say
they want to destroy it and they're
hell-bent on it they got a five-story
building just one organization charlie
kirk's organization in phoenix arizona
has a five-story building dedicated to
tearing down your democracy tearing down
your way of life so it makes sense when
you have constant constant right turning
point usa events i mean there was just
one the other day right and that's the
one i think that people were posting
clips or charlie kirk saying some
fascist ass [ __ ] well not only that but
then you had you know carrie lake the
fake talking about ron desantis and
trump having big dick energy which never
thought i would ever
speaking in arizona huh yeah speaking of
arizona i mean i mean let's keep in mind
let's let's remember that stormy daniels
said it would look like a [ __ ]
toad from mario
so
you small but this little fat mushroom
head why are they obsessed about talking
about other people's genitalia why are
they obsessed with they are absolutely
[ __ ] obsessed i have never met a
person in my life and been like i wonder
what's in their britches i never i have
never [ __ ] thought that i've never
been to a restroom and and thought what
is the person next to me what what kind
of genita i never i just well i mean
those are also the people that are like
peeking over you know just like uh who
was who was the representative what was
minnesota or i forgot who was who oh you
mean a lot that you mean the foot
tapping yeah the foot happened long time
ago no i know but i'm just saying like
that dude it's been in the dna right
it's something you're talking about this
is part of the republican party this
isn't yeah that's not new america
fascist party yeah they're like show me
your papers show me your penis that's
what they're doing whoa or you're you
know yeah
yeah right right blood coming out of
there who knows but they they constantly
i mean you're right they constantly talk
about it they are obsessed with it it is
very weird it's like look you have your
own whatever makeup you are you have
your own maybe just focus on that right
and not focus on listening to your own
[ __ ] someone else right like
if you've got something if you've got a
problem figure that out don't worry
about someone else's but charlie kirk
has a five-story building in arizona
designed to tear down our democracy and
ostracize people with he doesn't like
their genitalia like literally that is
his entire aim and and the the
if you go watch because i put the links
down below you go to ben's channel and
you go watch that whole debate where
charlie kirk is trying
trying to to frame up the abortion
debate it is
i mean
just in the way that they frame it up is
[ __ ] gross and it just and ben does a
good job in the debate to show you how
to counteract some of this stuff it's a
great debate to go watch um i think it's
it's almost a couple years old um but it
is a great great great interview or a
great debate to watch to know when they
say some of this dumb [ __ ] how to
counter them a little bit
and and because they're always coming up
with new ways just like they're coming
up with new ways to destroy our
democracy by by by
talking about how 14 fbi agents
invisible agents well i mean it's also
[ __ ] is this what the [ __ ] is this
you have to remember though it's not i
mean like they may be
coming up with new kind of uh tactics
but it's the same old thing right like
again i've said it before on the show
fascists are boring right they they are
not creative they will reuse the same
tactic they used
years and years and years before it and
years before that one and years before
that when like every time it cycles
through
they do the same thing they try to
restrict this limit that say you can't
do this
the only modifications are like what
happens
you know what is what is happening in
that current time so them saying like oh
14 agents came into my office and tried
to whistle blow on the conduct of the
doj
what are
as a coach as a coach
for wrestling he should know all about
blowing whistles
but it's you know it's nothing new it's
the same tactic of like let me disparage
or talk uh poorly against uh the actual
pro-democracy
pro-justice
uh department because if they're not
around right if we defund the fbi if we
don't have the doj then they can't come
after them or their party and the things
they're trying to accomplish in a
fascist regime
so that's i mean that's the that's the
kind of
this simplistic way of looking at it
right it's not new it's just them saying
new things don't you think this new jim
jordan thing this morning about 14 fbi
agents is because he's thinking he's
like okay how many because he said it on
fox news right i don't remember that but
he also in that same clip he also blast
big media
while also being on fox news right right
well but here's the thing so it's jim
jordan so you know right away that it's
likely to be a lie it's on face on fox
news so it even is more leaning into
that it's a lie but then you have to
really think about why he said 14 where
did he get that number because here's
what i think he's like
how many
do they think could possibly be
fascist in the fbi how many cult members
will they believe that isn't it and
that's where he came at 14. he's like um
maybe 19.
i'm surprised he didn't say 17 12.
that might be yeah that might be well
you know they might they might be doing
their um de matria or whatever the [ __ ]
it is oh 14 or what what what is 14 in
dimitri i don't know i'm sure over on
the dark web there i don't know
plus five minus one minus four plus it
you know it's right who knows who knows
what it could be who knows what a big
could be but let's get to the bottom of
it let's do this let's surf the tweety
tweets and trendy trends we got a lot of
video to get to let's start the
countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the show
you have reached the part where we round
up all the tweety tweets and journey
trends in the [ __ ] list
round up
boy do we have a lot of clips around the
morning let's get right to it let's not
waste a lot of time here
well
i'm telling you this uh marjorie taylor
green clip or
there's a new one out here's here's
another one there's another one since
this weekend well this is some kind of
[ __ ] nazi rally or something
republican women how many of these
things why do they have so many of these
things
four i don't know four sith republican
women of forsyth
county like forsyth
spelled with a y seems weird but all
right you know no judgment on the the
founders of that county but
uh
yeah i don't i don't know they always
have them right every weekend they've
got five simultaneous
events rallies conventions
you know whatever it might be they're i
mean they they're just trying to take
as much money as they can
and rile up as many people as they can
you know two birds one stone that's what
they're trying to do i mean even though
they're having multiple ones at the same
time that are all running in parallel
they're accomplishing the same thing
which is like you know we can get
somebody that's outraged whether it's
you know some part of the country it's
not isolated to just one event or one
every six months or whatever 12 months
they're having them like
every weekend every week they're just
rolling through to make sure that that
outrage with that party for something
they don't really understand
continues to go through into the
midterms well right because they have
they that this is what they've always
been good at is to keep the outrage and
that's why we uh broadcast every single
weekday two hours
every single weekday monday through
friday on youtube twitter twitch and
simulcasting from the minus touch
facebook page we have to get the message
out we have to get the pro-democracy
speech out and the reason why is because
we have to have strategic outrage at
counterbalance this nonsense listen
listen to what she says she she wants
them to commit crimes here watch
fight support people like representative
greene
get out and vote with you and your 20
closest friends and neighbors
okay so they're saying get out and vote
this sounds like democracy gabe this
sounds like the michael 20 interesting
specific number but okay right but
what wait for it wait for it remember
man 40 vote one two three
whatever they'll allow you to do
what what what what what was that uh
let's go back
november
oh so they're promoting voter fraud yeah
well of course they are good i'm not in
well i mean of course she laughs it off
she goes ha ha i'm just kidding but the
people don't see the laughing the jokes
or they take it seriously they're like
great okay i'll vote i'll vote one two
three four five times whatever right
right well they do that's i mean we've
watched as the only fraud that they've
ever found is trump supporters and it
seems to be isolated in trump areas like
the villages down in south florida let's
let's continue to listen here to see how
they play off her promoting voter fraud
georgia's almost anything so you never
know
get the [ __ ] out of here she's like
jesus christ what are you what's wrong
with you
thank you thank you she's like what's
wrong with you why why are you saying
commit voter fraud here what the hell is
wrong with you
it's craziness
that why
folks listen the reason why i show these
things is because without seeing them
you wouldn't know this [ __ ] happens and
it's super important that you're seeing
this stuff
it is super important just the same way
as you need to know exactly how they're
stealing our government she's saying out
loud hey just go vote one two three four
times who cares right it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
um there was a video that popped up um
this morning actually you know what let
me um you know i think i think i'll put
the uh the other version now let's play
it i like i like this version
so there was there was a a a
a fraud social post
from donald trump right
and i know yeah well hold on let's there
were one of many this week a lot of many
since friday
since since that search warrant was
released
there have been a lot of posts on uh on
fraud social as you said well it's it
it's getting kind of ridiculous and
there was one specifically where he said
to copy
copy this truth or something like that
as if it was something oh yeah yeah yeah
he he still thinks he's the president of
the united states and he still thinks
that anything he posts is declared as
some like like the michael scott moment
i declare bankruptcy like it's the same
i was not aware i was also not aware
that you could just say in the copy of
this tweet like or buy the copy of this
tweet like him declaring that
that the fbi would say oh you know what
guys what are we doing i don't even know
why other communications we've been even
trying those the one that we should
really be focusing on is true social
[ __ ] the facts forget the phone lines
don't even look at the emails we need to
be directly getting our information from
trump on true social because if he
that's the only place we can go
well this is one of the
the post
on fraud social that i thought was
a little weird he says
this is him
and and i'm quoting here but i'm not
using air quotes um
it says just received the strongest poll
numbers
i have ever gotten which is probably a
[ __ ] lie he said it yeah
and the largest amount of can campaign
contributions from the
people he put air quotes around people
okay now
when you do quotes like this air quotes
around a word what does it normally mean
like what do you normally take that is
like it's not that thing right it's
deferring like it's like oh i don't
really mean it that way right like from
the peasants not that right right right
like that's right right yeah it's the
vibe i'm getting yeah he goes on to say
the public gets the
scam which i think the scam is either
the big lie or the mar-a-lago thing i'm
not sure what which scam he's talking
about here but he puts quotes around
scam which means it's actually not a
scam if you go by when you're doing it
yeah and he continues to say but this
time much earlier than all of the others
which is really hard to read i don't
know what the hell he's talking about it
is a poorly
written sentence you know
is it a sentence the public gets the
quote-unquote scam so they're they're in
on it they understand it right so they
understand that i'm [ __ ] with them
like
this time right much earlier than all of
the others so i think he's saying now
that the scam is
you know joe biden the administration
their socialist regime and blah blah
blah [ __ ] but
he's saying like right now they've
caught on
to the scam which is like they're
attacking me
they're they're catching on earlier than
they were before right but this is all
projection and yeah
but it it reminded me
uh my wife is a big fan of friends and
it reminded me of the scene and friends
when joey and ross have the back and
forth about the air quotes
so you put together a little video here
let's let's take a look
at how joey responds to this this truth
social post
[Music]
i don't really know what that means
[Music]
i'm sorry
not using it right joe
so there you have it um joey and ross
explaining to us the fraud social post
that donald trump but you know the thing
is is he had a lot more um post over
yeah over the years
right but the one that everyone really
was focused on was this one where he
said like what we said before
that the copy of the of the truth or
something like this yeah by the copy by
the copy
of this of this truth obviously you know
it's like
his way of saying by the copy of the
tweet you know i guess so i think he's
saying it's an official message from the
president this one's not the one though
this is just one of them this is one
isn't this the one well this is this is
your response to this right yeah this is
your response you said oh that's right
yeah donald trump is now respectfully
in quotes right uh requesting that
government uh documents be returned to
him uh too bad so said guess he
shouldn't have stolen hid or lied about
the documents when the government
respectfully requested them multiple
times here is the uh the actual
fraud social post let me take down the
um the banner here
for a second and so we can see the whole
thing he says oh great
i don't like oh no
oh shucks right
it has just been learned he just learned
it he that someone taught him this thing
that he learned he learned real good
that the fbi
in its now famous raid of mar-a-lago
what's famous because you're a criminal
yeah but also let's not let's not forget
that he made it
he made it front news stuff because he
released a new he released a newsletter
his like announcement right
fbi didn't come storming through the
doors they were all dressed up in
civilian clothes
and then they went and did their thing
but the only reason that everyone knows
about it and the only reason that it was
became like top story news was because
trump made it he got out there he posted
he posted a [ __ ] long ass
uh response which is which was done
after he watched it live
happened on on uh to mar-a-lago from you
know from new york he watched it on
unfortunately on their closed their
clothes
their security cameras but here's the
thing
is
what you're saying is if donald trump
would not have said anything
we actually wouldn't have received a
copy of the warrant we wouldn't have
received the receipt to know what the
documents are he is always
a hundred percent always his worst
[ __ ] enemy like if he just would have
said okay let's keep this quiet let's
not talk about this thing
let's see where this goes then maybe
just maybe it wouldn't be such a big
deal but he continues to say here
took boxes a privilege a privileged
quote attorney-client
material i don't know why he's quote
again he he uses the quotes really
so then it's not really attorney
oh right but that's what he again if
he's using air quotes then it's i don't
know right and then he says and also
executive again no it's not executive
right right privileged material
which they knowingly should not have
taken here's the thing
they had a warrant right they had a
warrant and when you go in to
serve a warrant in the raid that he's
saying when you raid a police
whether it's a search warrant or a raid
yeah when they go in and they find
evidence of other crimes they can take
that stuff too
like he is just waking up this morning i
i think this was saturday or sunday he
posted this
um he just woke up and realized oh god
they took other evidence of other crimes
that have nothing to do with the other
documents there was a complete facepalm
where he's like oh no you know and
melania's like
good
he's like whoever i hope they folded my
panties and put them back in the drawer
no i mean
he's always telling on himself because
he keeps talking about melania's closet
and the safe and i bet we're going to
find out that there's crimes evidence of
crimes in the safe and there's evidence
of crimes that he hid in her closet
right people vet money on that yeah well
he's brought it up two or three times
now in these messages on true social so
it's like why do you keep fixated
on the safe
and also why do you keep fixated on her
[ __ ] closet like
okay let's just get it out in the open
here when uh when as a law enforcement
agency comes through and they start
searching your place they're not going
to fold your [ __ ] back up and put it
back in the drawer and they're going to
[ __ ] take it out dump it on the
ground go through out and be like great
nothing here cool move that off to the
side next door move off to the side
they're not going to then clean up be
like oh [ __ ] which drawer were the socks
in i was in the bottom drawer no they're
not gonna do that they're not and
they're not [ __ ] cleaners they're
about the people that are gonna go
through and make sure oh we have tidy up
and
as if we were never here no but they
gave me the went from he went from
saying
her closet and then he started using the
plural form of it yeah he said he moved
to classics closets so she has more than
one which i can imagine that melania
trump would have probably more than one
club many many rooms there you really
try to get you know and it is kind of
gross and it's kind of hard to do but if
you get inside the brain of this [ __ ]
toddler this this man baby
he would have me i would imagine he
would think if i have this evidence of
crimes i could just put it in her closet
that way it's not mine it's hers it's
now in her closet so they can't even if
they come in to get it they can't go in
her closet to get it because it's hid
behind her brawls i don't understand how
we didn't know that like when someone
gets a search one
that they can search the entirety right
the rest but also
the fact that he might believe that if
he puts something in her closet he goes
well she's taking the blame that's not
right it works i didn't have it i didn't
she yeah
it was was it on your residence got it
okay just because it was in the closet
doesn't infer that she was the person i
mean i don't know maybe she was involved
but i doubt it but the fact that he's
like oh if i hide it over there
one they'll never find it
two i won't take the blame like that's
the logic that the stable genius known
as donald trump has when it comes to
committing crimes and also projecting
and then admitting to the crime and then
saying well i didn't do a crime you guys
were talking about the crime it's like
no one brought up the crime until you
right no one brought up melania's
closets until he brought it up closet no
again no one would have ever known no no
or about the safe either the craziest
part to me
is is that
he knows he has security cameras like
everyone claims and i call him the
cheeto dust mobster now i'm making fun
of him because everyone claims he's like
a mobster gabe if he's like a mobster
he's like the world's [ __ ] worst
mobster off the world's worst mobster
like this is beyond parody and satire of
what a mob boss would actually do would
record themselves
moving around boxes of evidence of
crimes like why would they record like
oh yeah hey hey johnny turn on the turn
on the uh the camera there as we get
this body out of the trunk and we show
where we're going to bear it like no
like also yeah like they also uh did not
you know delete the footage for the surv
with the surveillance footage that they
had at mar-a-lago which means that then
they were you know then the fbi was like
great we now have got it that's a little
video
we have you on 4k
i can't wait to see this video oh yeah
yeah i can't wait do you think they have
audio on it too or is it just the video
no probably just video if i'd imagine oh
but i i i just even better because then
there can be like a narration right i
just want to see like on one like i was
joking with these this weekend it
reminds me of like those babysitter 80
movie 80s movies where like the parents
are on their way back home like it's
almost like ferris bueller like their
parents are on their way back home and
ferris bueller whoever else in like
these 80s style movies are like running
to make it back or like cleaning up
after a party and right as the parents
walk in they like sweep the final like
beer underneath the piano or something
like they were hiding in the box yeah
and they're like oh hey hey hey mom hey
dad what what's going on right there
right yeah they're hiding the dead body
behind behind
melania's underwear drawer right exactly
so in this case like the the you know
the the feds are like all right great we
have everything and the lord is like yep
you got everything
meanwhile these guys are like waiting on
the side with probably on camera like
box like oh [ __ ] you can even see
someone like out on the balcony like
yeah right yeah she's like up against a
balcony like in some weird ass position
like on the ceiling
like pushing the box against the wall oh
my god that's how i imagine this was
going down like it's ridiculous it is
funny it is also very very sad that this
is the reality we live in where
we have this unprecedented moment where
a former president
was stealing top secret classified
documents and was like unclassified it's
like doesn't work that way man it does
not it does not also why would you need
this stuff that only people can see in a
very very secure location well here's
the thing
because he is dictating here he is
declaring
by here's what he says in this post by
copy of this truth he yells truth yeah i
guess that's to signify that it's it's
not a fraud he's real he should put
quote truth truth yeah he should have
put quotes
um he says i respectfully request that
these documents be immediately returned
to the location from which they came
thank you i don't understand well here's
the thing
the one thing i didn't point out was
from which they came
is the government right right
okay great we did we took them from you
because that's not where it came from
and took it back to the government which
is where it came from it's like a little
kid taking a cookie out of a cookie jar
and and the parent have to go you've
already had four cookies
and you're about to puke right you have
to give me this cookie and we're going
to put it back in the cookie jar and
once it goes back in the cookie jar it's
like give me my cookie back i want it
back where it came from like that's
exactly where it came from um
now you have these republicans trying to
defend donald trump
and i thought this was one of the
greatest clips over the weekend we
watched mike turner who is the ranking
republican member of the intelligence
committee which we didn't know who this
[ __ ] was really until he came
out this last week and gave his his
little his little treason espionage
i mean we didn't know a lot of these
people either that's what i was saying
last week i was like some of the people
i've never even heard of but they made
themselves known on a national stage
because they decided to say
donald trump was well within his right
to take these documents and go to
florida with him
well let's see what let's see what mike
turner says about taking these documents
home listen to this this is fantastic
bipartisan calls for do that mm-hmm put
the materials in a room let us see them
and then we can tell you what our answer
is and what our you know discernment is
number one i don't want any republicans
looking at classified documents at this
point i really don't
i mean i'm dead serious this is
ridiculous that we have to continue this
nonsense where these people are serious
about government serious about national
security especially the [ __ ] they said
over the last week but listen listen
when she asked him
about
if he would take what he would do with
these documents
of whether or not this is a true
national security threat or whether or
not this is an abusive discretion by
attorney general garland do you take
home documents marked special access
i like i was like no of course not no
why would i do that
that is illegal
you're breaking the law i wouldn't i
would go to federal prison i understand
my position i would not do that
no and and what's funny is he's trying
to feed her a line of [ __ ] right and
she gives no [ __ ] no [ __ ] what he just
said right she knows she knows the truth
the truth is you know you know what
happened here as a crime and you
wouldn't do it even yourself because you
know that for a fact and yet you still
sit here and try to gaslight
right and you know i've cnn she did a
good job and i'm gonna finish the clip
here because she continues to press him
but they still need to say then why are
you lying like that should be the
follow-up that's the follow-up question
then why are you gaslighting my audience
and yet you're casting down you know
quite frankly you know i've been i've
been in the oval office see um with just
zeppelin and i'd be very surprised if he
has actual documents at rice level
immediate national security threat
well the documents just to be clear
several sets and you're aware of that
because you've seen the property receipt
you're casting doubt you want
information you don't actually have that
information on which to base that
conclusion again she's being very nice
here way too [ __ ] nice she should say
stop why are you lying
stop lying you're lying and gaslighting
my audience you're not
what you're doing what you're doing is
all [ __ ] you know that you can't
take these documents home you know that
any other person on earth couldn't take
these documents home what makes you
think donald trump is any kind of
special person that he could remove
these documents
you're gaslighting and lying to that's
what she should say she's being way too
nice here i mean i appreciate that she
asked a question and caught him in his
own [ __ ] [ __ ] but she did not
point that out and she didn't hammer him
with it and pin it to him on his chest
that i'm full of [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
what these that's what the media needs
to start doing is pin these people as
full of [ __ ] [ __ ] not this oh well
that's your opinion i don't give a [ __ ]
what your opinion is i don't care what
you say you believe it's all [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's lies in its
gas line stop so let's let's finish
because the ending here at this point
but you yourself would not take home
documents that are marked special access
you would not take home this sensitive
compartmented information
or
yeah he totally breezes over it and
again yeah it's because she really
doesn't hold him to account and i
appreciate that she's trying to i really
do
but you're not doing the full work of
getting him to really admit that he's
full of [ __ ] and that you're lying and
even if you've got to go back and forth
and he never admits it he's still a
[ __ ] liar yeah still
a [ __ ] liar
but she asked i mean she she asked the
question that everyone should be asking
inside they should keep asking which is
would you do this
no got it why are you saying that he can
do it and those are the only two
questions that really matter here like
you're saying like there should be a
follow-up obviously she didn't you know
allow for it but
in these moments that you look at this
it's like simple question very
straightforward
would you do this
no okay then why are you telling other
people
that trump can do this
and also the fact that he's trying he's
like oh well i don't really think it's
that classified
if you have the doj and the fbi saying
there are documents in here one
that even the fbi did not know existed
because only a certain group of people
know of their existence that's that
should be telling right there but then
two
it's like oh they planted the evidence
they wouldn't even know what to [ __ ]
plant
because only so many people know about
it and the only people that do know
about it can see it in a skiff or
someone that's protected or secure
private
well i i
this is this is crazy that we can't
agree
that the media needs to handle these
people in a certain way like mike turner
she knew exactly what mike turner was
gonna say she knew exactly that she was
gonna gaslight on cnn she watched the
press conference she watched she watched
as he justified in front of a microphone
that that donald trump can do whatever
he wants whenever he wants because he's
donald trump she knew that was going to
be his angle and she and she did she
asked the question she got him on the
record of not really responding i mean
he said no i wouldn't do that but i mean
he wouldn't say why you wouldn't do it
she didn't follow up why why wouldn't
you why wouldn't you do that why
wouldn't you take these documents why is
it so egregious for someone like you to
take it but not someone like him the
follow-up is important here and the
pressure on these fascists is important
and the reason why is because we're
getting [ __ ] dumber by the minute
dumber by the minute and here's proof
here are people cheering
cheering marjorie taylor green as she
gaslights these people in this room
about batteries that there's no such
things as batteries and lights and i
don't know what the [ __ ] she's talking
about but listen to this ladies
and we're all here in georgia can we
just say thank god for air conditioning
[Applause]
i'm agreeing with with air conditioning
yeah i wish i i only have a window unit
so it gets [ __ ] hot in l.a right you
know central air is a real a really nice
a nice luxury i like air conditioning i
like it let's see where she's going with
this talk about refrigerators i
personally like my refrigerator i like
to keep my beverages cold too and my
like you know my my lunch meat i keep it
in the cheese yeah i got a freezer too
right the vegetable right well you know
sometimes you gotta freeze these things
sometimes you gotta breathe so i'm i'm
i'm all in here i don't know what what
the problem is two for two right let's
listen i know you all like yours what
about washing machines and dryers
gabe i use washing machines and dryers
to to wash our clothes uh-huh yeah yeah
that's what we use
they run off electric
i don't know where she's going with this
but let's
see how stupid it gets
lord please god don't make me scrub
clothes in a bucket and have to hang
them out on the line when we switch over
to wind turbines and solar panels
what did she just say did she just say
we're gonna have to hand wash clothes
when we switch to wind turbines and
solar panels what the [ __ ] is she
talking about does she think does she
think if we switch to renewable energy
that that energy can't be stored
and and distributed like energy is
stored and distributed now does she
it's like
oh my god okay okay okay wait let me let
i'm just i'm just trying to like i'm
just trying to put my mtg cap on and
think like her okay so well thinking is
the problem here yeah i know i know i've
i've gotta i've gotta remove some
elements of my brain for a moment uh
okay so she's saying
that everything else works normally you
have electricity and they provide power
to these different devices right correct
ac refrigerator washer dryer we all
agree listening watching we agree these
are great luxuries to have right so now
she says okay well if
water and solar renewable energy is
involved then you
you don't
you do
it's it we don't get electricity
because
texas paul brings up something here in
the chat he says guys she is talking
about the gop plan for women if they win
the midterms where they're where they're
washing clothes yeah
but that's that doesn't make any hold on
but marger taylor green said that men
were the superior gender right which
also goes against the whole fact of like
if the if she really believes in their
superior gender and men are better than
women then why is she as a woman in
office just using her logic i don't know
just using her logic but again
do you think this person has logic
i'm trying to i'm trying to remove any
any sanity from my brain right now to
make sense of what you said but she's
saying that like she enjoys these
luxuries washing drying refrigerator ac
those use electricity right but in her
mind
renewable energy doesn't create
electricity so then the whole world
would go without power
and then she would need to use one of
those metal wood
uh ribbed slats to wash you understand
that wind turbines and solar panels
create electricity does she even
understand that i don't think she does
because listen to it gets dumber you
think oh there's no way this can get oh
wait no well i mean yeah okay it gets
dumber baby it gets way dumber let's
listen
i'm gonna be really pissed off about
that
i want to stay up later at night i don't
want to have to go to bed when the sun
sets
it's so silly i i mean all of this is
absolutely insane yeah
oh my god so these does she does she
think okay does she think that if the
sun goes down
the solar panels don't work
well
she she also thinks
well gabe
these people have no clue and they have
not been included on a battery maybe
what they should do is charge their
phone charge the battery on their phone
and just google or duckduckgo whichever
it is
and just once their battery is charged
and it has electricity inside the phone
and it's stored in there maybe what they
should do is just look up
like how to store electricity from i
don't know wind turbines and solar
panels here's the frightening thing she
knows this she knows it's all [ __ ]
she knows this is [ __ ] just like
jewish space lasers are [ __ ] i don't
know though are you sure like part of me
wants to be like yeah she doesn't know
or like rather she she knows it's not
true right what she's saying she knows
space
i look at this and i say
ah she did talk about jewish space
lasers or lasers owned by jewish people
right like either way you look at it
she's probably also someone that was
pushing bamboo ballots and italian
satellites pushing data down to
to dominion software uh voting machines
like
i don't know
if the
things are really clicking up there you
know so like you know part of me won't
say oh yeah you know what i'll give her
i'll give her the benefit of the doubt
and she really doesn't believe this she
understands how electricity works and
she knows that renewable energy
is
is something that works
but there's another part of me that's
like
but does she
well i mean some are saying in the chat
that she's not pretending she's really
that dumb but the thing that frightens
me the most is that people are cheering
for this
like why are you cheering like what what
it's the same people that cheer when
they're like we had a million or you
know we had like right way less deaths
right yeah yeah like ben was giant again
hey
any number over one or any number over
zero
is not something to applause for it's
[ __ ] nuts well you know and again
there's more of this insanity over the
weekend fox news um some some [ __ ]
stupid-ass you know traitor show on fox
news they're talking about the espionage
act and they're talking about uh donald
trump being a traitor well trying to
they're trying to get right and really
it's hilarious to watch these people run
face first into the point like face
first into it and still walk away with
their head straight up their asses like
how how aren't you hearing yourselves
even like you're talking amongst
yourselves
you're saying things out loud they're
saying to you you're you're and and they
come away with the evidence in front of
them with a completely different
conclusion than the evidence watch this
clip it is [ __ ] baffling to me
no
[Laughter]
well look that sounds like it covers
everything right and the warren covers
everything so we got everything covered
um
they are not going to prosecute him
on the espionage and i that may be true
that may be true but they're definitely
going to prosecute him for something
yeah i mean i i would imagine the espn i
mean dude they've got there are four
jurisdictions we got new york
georgia right d.c
uh in florida right he's also in the
[ __ ] jurisdiction he's completely [ __ ]
right you know he is complete like he
dude he
you know he [ __ ] around and now he's
really finding out right now it's one of
these four are gonna get him you know
and i wouldn't be surprised if this [ __ ]
is mentioned during the january 6th
hearings when they come back in
september well i think that's just as it
goes [ __ ] yourself i think that's what
triggers but andrew mccarthy here who is
a former assistant u.s attorney he
actually he actually says this he
actually says what we're saying in so
many words watch i would again point out
that there were three statutes that are
cited in the warrant two of them have
nothing to do with classified
information it's it's just government
records right so
i think the objective here was to gather
as much information as they could they
used i'm not when i say pretextual i'm
not saying that they lied to get the
warrant but the they had the excuse of
going in to get the classified
information so they exploited it to get
everything
to get everything
so what he's saying here is exactly what
a lot of people been saying that hey
even if they had the reasonable
uh
the ability the probable cause to search
and the federal judge gave them the
search warrant they went and got this
stuff if they saw other crimes when
they're there
they have the ability to prosecute for
those crimes that's what trump's been
yelling and screaming about with these
other oh they took information it has to
do with other crimes not with the
warrant they can't take that they can't
take that evidence of crimes but this
guy's saying that same thing but watch
watch the response here it's baffling
they went in and they found something
else uh that they deemed to be in the
commission of another crime that wasn't
necessarily with respect to these
documents they could take it they could
use their judgment at that point right
the law the law says that so for example
if the agents go in and they are looking
for crime a and they see obvious
evidence of crime b if i go in on a gun
case and i see a pile of narcotics on
the table i can take the narcotics i'm
not required to turn a blind eye to it
but here
they had a warrant that told them they
could take everything and it's not tied
to particular crimes and it's certainly
not tied only to classified crimes right
so
i don't see this ever resulting in a
classified information indictment i
think what they're trying to do is
they're trying to make a fraud on the
government or obstruction of congress
case on trump in connection with january
6 and they're hoping they hit a home
fishing expedition
okay so and let me back it up just a
minute listen to what she says in the
end
because this is important all that stuff
he just said all of it he just said the
evidence that we watched the last week
of donald trump freaking the [ __ ] out
all the stuff he said the [ __ ] we see in
the god damn inventory that they made
when they left with the [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] evidence of crimes
listen to what she says catch it catch
it here with january 6 and they're
hoping that it'll hold a fishing
expedition it's a fishing expedition
all this talk they're talking to
themselves they're having this banter
back and forth they're running face
first into the [ __ ] truth and she's
like that's a fishing expedition
like what do you mean like like like
catfish trout what are you talking about
you [ __ ] boneheads it's not a fishing
expedition this guy's telling you hey
they had a reasonable cause to go in
there and if they find other crimes
they're gonna charge them with those
crimes not the document crimes which i
actually disagree with them i think the
department of justice is gonna pile on
as much [ __ ] as they possibly can on
this [ __ ] at this point they're
like [ __ ] this we're just gonna bury
this guy in charges and indictments and
and one will stick one will catch this
[ __ ] in the face
and and and even here on fox news even
with their audience hearing the truth
they still can't help but gaslight them
here's the end and it proves his
argument that it's him against a system
that's after him and that this was
political
no that's the exact opposite of what
everyone just said like the exact
opposite the exact opposite of what was
just said is what you're saying they i
mean well they don't wanna they don't
wanna listen they they have they
what they're looking for is confirmation
bias right they have their own idea of
what went down and the unfair treatment
that donald trump went through by having
his home rated now he will use the
quotes rated because it wasn't actually
rated you know like
just a lesson for donald trump how to
use quotes here it was a legal search
that was done it wasn't rated or
anything
your door was not [ __ ] broken down
they didn't [ __ ] come ramming through
with guns blazing coming in the
helicopter do all this crazy [ __ ] they
literally came in
in civilian clothes had a search warrant
that was signed by a republican judge
and they were like yeah we can't say no
to this they you
you have you have complete
uh ev you have you have a complete case
here to to justify why
you would you would enter right there
was an illegal crime there was a crime
being committed somewhere within this
[ __ ]
and you guys have an evidence of of of
that kind of playing out and before it
gets worse you need to act now so yeah i
will sign off on this thing now this is
one of his lawyers i'm not sure which
one he's convinced
uh this one is that he's convinced to be
his lawyer that's probably going to go
to prison herself or lose their law
license i mean her and christina bob i
hold it rico no [ __ ] but but here she's
on
trader tv news network talking about the
and she's at betminster you can see
betminster new jersey she's she's near
trump somewhere um but here she's
talking about the the search warrant
definitely what we're dealing with here
it's
i say it a hundred times if he's not
leading in the polls i i've sat across
from him every time he gets frustrated i
say to him mr president
if you would like me to resolve all your
litigation
you should announce that you are not
running for office and all of this will
stop
that that's what they want
yeah there's a lot of truth to that
no there's absolutely no truth there is
uh zero truth truth to that
the idea that you would say
like as a lawyer now
there's some background i'll give to her
in a moment but
alina here
somehow i mean well then again rudy
giuliani had a bar like you know a la la
the license to be a lawyer in the state
of new york as well so i
don't know if maybe it's a new york
thing or what but
the fact that she goes look these things
will go away they'll stop attacking you
the charges will be dropped if you don't
run
that's not how that works
you commit a crime
you're still committed to crying they're
still going to come after you for the
[ __ ] crime
it's not because oh donald trump's
running so we should just throw stuff at
him and see what comes out of it
like
didn't just make up the documents were
in in mar-a-lago they just make up that
they requested multiple times and they
didn't do anything
also she went to harvard wait what the
[ __ ] man she went to harvard yeah
another person she well
i'm not i don't want to offend any
lawyers or attorneys out there i know
several i guess but there are people
that went to harvard that are giving
harvard you know you got but here's the
thing yeah but it can't be that hard to
pass a bar can it can it i need to ask a
lawyer this i need to get pulled back
karen on here somebody on here to
reassure me
that this is not just some crazy ass
thing that you can just go and you know
pay to get because it really does seem
like it is super easy
super easy to get a bar to pass the bar
but for people who don't know elena here
alina
habba
is a racist
oh no way no way yeah well tony you
might not know it but she is crazy there
is a whole
if if people want to google just go
elena just google it because i won't
really get into it right now but just
google alina have a a-l-i-n-a h-a-b-b-a
and then put racist and you'll read all
about the way that she treats employees
at the law firm that she works at and
what she said about uh tisch james
and her treatment of others it is she's
not she's incompetent and racist at the
same time uh which makes sense and i
said that online i was like it totally
makes sense that she would be um
uh representing donald trump
and that's only one of them
well speaking of someone who needs
representation
this is a
a phone call it's a 9-1-1 call made and
i don't know when this was this is
recent i think a 9-1-1 call made by
lauren bobert's neighbors
where one of lauren bobert's uh mass
shooters i mean sons was um
speeding up and down the street in a
razor like a dune buggy type vehicle uh
on their city street and they asked him
to slow down apparently
a reasonable thing to do right right
just say hey slow down stop going so
damn fast you're gonna hurt somebody or
yourself and apparently lauren
beaubert's um penis exposure i mean
husband
jason oh yeah came down in his truck
with this son and started threatening
these people and they have to do that
well you know whether were there miners
around that is that is something that
we're gonna have to probably find out
later but let's listen to a little bit
of this phone call just a little bit of
it it's like six minutes long but let's
uh two phone calls that were made in
this video let's listen to a little bit
of this phone call
9-1-1 with the address of the emergency
repeat the address for me one more time
to make sure i have it correct
still colorado
okay perfect
your phone number you're calling me from
sir
and now it's he's driving away i think
just about fighting there's uh
it's bad at lauren bobert's jackass
husband jason
makes sense i love him i love how he he
immediately calls he he says lauren
bober's jackass husband like that's that
like
they that's how they refer to him inside
this neighborhood right that's how her
[ __ ] neighbors in colorado feel
better
like and it goes on to talk about how
i mean he's trying to he runs over the
guy's mailbox destroying his property
apparently with his truck yeah he's
telling him to get the [ __ ] off his
property with the guy on the phone
called this telling them get the [ __ ]
out the property and of course the uh
penis exposure jason bobert is is
yelling back at him or something
yeah i was gonna say you're i was like i
mean you're you're telling me that the
guy
jason beaubert
exposed his penis
to minors in a bowling alley is the same
guy
that would swear and be a a nuisance to
neighbors in in in the area and drive
over a mailbox you're saying that's the
same guy right yeah he he seems
reasonable
oh weird okay he seems really reasonable
it really is um yeah also somebody
brings up a good point i totally forgot
about that uh
destroying a mailbox is federal crime
yeah right well i mean it's it well also
uh destroying someone else's property
like their yard right um intentionally
trying to hit him with the truck i mean
there's there's could be crimes here um
the thing that gets me the most and i'm
not gonna find it because we're running
out of time here you gotta go listen
this i retweeted it to go to the top of
my feed
but the guy on the phone call
calls jason as dumb as a post
that's the disgrace just jackass and
he's as dumb as a post so apparently
lauren boward and her husband are like
just a a match made in heaven gabe
there's one more piece of video that i
want to show before we go um and it's
one of the sweetest most delicious
pieces of video that came out of this
weekend when you watch um again a [ __ ]
sandwich eat a [ __ ] [ __ ] sandwich here
did we watch this on friday we did like
we did we watched this i gotta watch it
again i can't help it we did watch this
on
but it's so delicious watch
as these two [ __ ] sandwiches eat each
other oral could you think that we're
safer now than we were under president
trump when he was willing to put
missiles into syrian air bases with
russians on the base what's going on
here sir he didn't understand because he
didn't understand fundamentally much of
anything about international affairs he
could have just stopped fundamentally
anything yeah like he didn't have to
continue no he's he's just throwing salt
in the wound now he's like i'm gonna i'm
gonna add as much detail as i can here
oh my god let's keep going his decisions
were not based on a coherent philosophy
or a coherent problem
and that made us safer i mean can you he
had presidency
you know what made us less safe is when
biden pulled us out of afghanistan 13
americans died and now this trump stands
and now the taliban tells us
that's right
are you out of your mind same thing they
wouldn't oh i can't help it this is a
one-year anniversary of us
finally getting out of that slog of a
war that we should never really been in
in the first place in afghanistan thank
you to president um biden for actually
executing what was a shitty deal that
trump made with him
there was a contract they made a deal
and biden was like well my predecessor
made the deal and if i back out of this
i don't know what will happen
you know and it was a shitty deal yeah
it was a terrible deal oh yeah it was
horrible but also it's like trump you
know he's like i make the best deals the
best ones you know like he's going to
brag about his business acumen and how
he's the you know out of the deal
the guy's a [ __ ] idiot
and he thinks that everything he does
is amazing well of course he does of
course he does because it is gabe uh
texas paul says damn it don't make me
agree with john bolton that's what i
love about that clip is i actually hate
john bolton [ __ ] john bolton but it is
so funny to watch him eviscerate trump
because he hates trump because of what
trump did to him and how these people
still think they're going to gain
loyalty through him and speaking
speaking of loyalty tomorrow tomorrow
texas paul i hope he joins us
for his loyal fans to give them the
texas rundown on texas tuesdays texas
paul tuesday i know we gotta we gotta
come up with the name of this texas paul
come by tomorrow since you're in the
chat come by tomorrow we'll talk about
some texas talk i know betto's kicking
ass and taking names yeah we haven't we
haven't spoken since that i don't i
think i don't think we have no well see
metal clip right
no i well i did we talk about the one
where he's like [ __ ] can we talk
about it yeah i don't know what we
talked about
texas fall tomorrow we'll play that clip
we'll get texas paul's response of how
betto's doing with these [ __ ]
um out there and let me tell you
something tomorrow uh is tuesday and
stay tuned at noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter twitch
as you should every single weekday
for two full hours simulcasting from the
midas touch facebook page don't forget
we got the new qr code down here in the
new link support dot tonymichaelspod.com
please give us some of your support if
you can support
pro democracy speech today it's super
important that you join us here every
single weekday for your strategic
outrage
so that you can go spread that
pro-democracy message just like betto is
doing in texas fetterman's doing in
pennsylvania warnock's doing in georgia
kelly's doing in arizona and tim ryan is
doing in ohio and all the democrats are
accomplishing what the american people
want currently right now and the reason
why is because
they are pro-democracy this is what
democracy delivers you delivers you it
does not get books banned in florida did
you hear about this right before we go
desantis wants to get rid of book fairs
at schools i'm not [ __ ] you what
book fairs he wants to get rid of book
bears i just want to say as a kid raised
on a scholastic book fair
those were the best moments during the
month right when you got the little the
little paper yeah you got the little
paper it's like oh you know
buying anything
enjoying the time of like cruising
through books piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] so
keep your outrage up have strategic
outrage make sure to support
pro-democracy speech whether it's here
or it's others on the midas touch
network or others are in in our country
support pro democracy speech today
wherever you can until tomorrow
until tomorrow game noon eastern 11
central nine pacific on youtube twitter
twitch and simulcasting from the mind
facebook page
surf's up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking